Good morning,
all.
Let's get going.
So I guess you had your quiz
review yesterday.
I hope you guys didn't beat up
on (name of TA) and who else was
it?
(Name of TA) too much.
As you know,
the quiz is tomorrow.
And unfortunately MIT couldn't
give us one big room so we are
broken up into three rooms.
And you will go to your room
based on the first letter of
your last name.
OK, so today we shall cover a
topic called "Large Signal
Analysis".
So in the last couple lectures
we looked at one dependent
sources abstractly,
and then we looked at an
amplifier built using a
practical dependent source
called the MOSFET.
Now, the MOSFET had to be
operated in a given region of
its operation in order to behave
like a current source.
And while it behaved like a
current source you would get
amplification or a FET
amplifier.
So that was in the past two
lectures.
What you are going to do today
is called large signal analysis,
and this is a loaded term.
So large signal analysis means
something very specific in our
business, and I will describe to
what that is.
This analysis involves looking
at a circuit containing,
for example,
a MOSFET and figuring out how
to get that device to operate in
a way that the MOSFET was always
in saturation.
So you had to figure out,
based on parameters that you
could control,
how to establish those
parameters so that the circuit
operated in a way that the
MOSFET was always in saturation.
So large signal analysis
involves that.
And although the examples we
use, use the MOSFET,
the same kind of analysis can
apply to any other device.
Remember, your MOSFET is a
primitive element that we use as
an example in this course.
There are other primitive
elements that you can use.
The course notes,
for example,
discusses a couple other
devices.
One is the "bipolar junction
transistor", the BJT,
and works through a complete
example from start to finish
involving a circuit containing a
bipolar junction transistor.
And you can do a large signal
analysis of that device as well.
It turns out that you need to
operate that device in an
interesting region of its
operating space,
and so you can conduct a large
signal analysis of a circuit
containing that device and
figure out how best to operate
that circuit.
So that is large signal
analysis, and we will do an
example and explain how this is
done using an example today.
So to quickly review where we
have been so far,
we looked at this little
structure here,
our MOSFET amplifier.
Notice that when I write a
voltage at a node,
that's a short form for saying
I am looking at the voltage
between the ground node and the
node at which the voltage is
written down.
So VO here and VI applied here.
This is a very,
very common circuit that we
use.
To emphasize one more point,
in general, in the kind of
circuits we look at both in this
course and in real life,
there are a few patterns that
we use very commonly that keep
repeating all the time.
Very often you don't have to
look at every possible
permutation and combination of
how things could be connected.
This sort of connecting thing
is very, very,
very common.
And you will see a lot of this
pattern.
And we do the equivalent
circuit for this.
In the equivalent circuit we
replace the MOSFET with a
dependent source provided this
operated in the saturation
region.
So I will just say while
operating under saturation the
equivalent circuit would look
like this, VO,
VI.
And IDS for the dependent
source was given by K/2
(VI-VT)^2.
So this was an amplifier.
Here was the equivalent circuit
while this device was in
saturation.
And to operate in saturation,
I said that certain properties
need to be true for the MOSFET.
And there are two properties
that need to be true for this to
be operating in saturation.
One is that its gate to source
voltage needs to be greater than
VT, so VGS for the MOSFET should
be greater than VT.
And the second one was that the
output voltage needed to be
greater than the input voltage
minus one threshold drop.
And this was the same as VDS
for the MOSFET,
this was the same as VGS for
the MOSFET.
So what are we really saying
here?
What we are saying is that
look, we built this circuit
using a MOSFET,
and it is up to us as engineers
to choose its operating points
in a way that these two
properties hold.
For example,
to make the first condition
true, I can discipline myself to
operate such that VI is always
greater than VT.
Similarly, I can choose VS,
RL and VI in a way that this
condition is true,
which says that the drain to
source voltage across my MOSFET
drain and source should be
greater than VI minus VT.
As an example,
if VI was 2 volts and VT was,
say, 1 volt,
then what I am saying is that
VO should be greater than or
equal to 2 minus 1 or 1 volt.
So I need to keep this high,
2, 3, 4, 5, whatever,
a high voltage so that this guy
stays in saturation.
The relevant readings for the
material that we are going to
cover in the course notes are in
7.5.1 and 7.6.
So that is pretty much a review
of where we were.
We said we could build an
amplifier.
Its equivalent circuit was
shown on the right.
And, provided that,
I discipline myself to operate
in the saturation region or to
have the MOSFET operating in the
saturation region,
then this would work like an
amplifier and all would be good
with the world.
So today --
-- we look at large signal
analysis of a circuit.
And an example would be this
circuit up here containing a
MOSFET.
And, again, as I mentioned
earlier, a large signal analysis
is a loaded term in 6.002,
or for that matter in circuits.
And large signal analysis
involves two steps.
The first step involves writing
down the transfer function of
your little circuit.
In our case,
VO is the output,
VI is the input,
so involves writing down VO
versus VI.
Simply write down the transfer
function.
In other words,
the relationship between the
output and the input for that
circuit.
And, in our case,
again, we've disciplined
ourselves to adhere to the
"saturation discipline".
And the second part of large
signal analysis is to find out
the valid input operating range.
Find out for the given circuit
parameters, let's say I apply a
VS and I use some value of RL
and I use a given MOSFET,
which has a given value of VT.
The question then is that what
is a valid set of input voltages
that would operate the circuit
in a way that I would be in
saturation.
And so find out the valid input
range, and this would give me a
corresponding output range --
-- for saturation operation of
the MOSFET.
That is what we will dwell on
in the lecture today.
So what we are saying here is
that if I am careful with how I
apply VI for a given value of RL
and VS and for a given choice of
my MOS transistor then I can
stay within saturation provided
I select my input voltages
carefully.
And the analysis that we will
go through today will figure out
what that range of input
voltages is.
And, again, I will use this as
a motivating example,
the MOSFET amplifier.
But in general large signal
analysis would apply to any
other circuit as well.
For example,
in recitation you may learn
about other circuits containing
a MOSFET.
And you can do a large signal
analysis of other circuits
containing a MOSFET or you might
learn about some other devices
like the bipolar junction
transistor, and you could do the
same kind of analysis for that
device.
So remember that the MOSFET
amplifier here is an example.
I will be using that as a
driving example to explain large
signal analysis.
So the first step,
as I mentioned earlier,
is to get the VO versus VI.
And in general for some circuit
that you build the output will
not even be a voltage.
There are certain circuits
where the output might be some
kind of a current.
Let's say I am building some
kind of a circuit where I would
like the output current or the
current through some edge of the
circuit to depend on some input.
In that case the transfer
function would be the output
current versus VI.
And if I had an input current
here it would be output current
versus input current,
you know, whatever the given
problem tells you.
So this is under the saturation
discipline.
And I will not rederive this
for you.
You can apply a good old
technique like the analytical
method.
Or you can use the graphical
method to get the appropriate
answer here.
I wanted to point out in a
quick aside that why do we care
about graphical analysis?
Once you have the analytical
method, why do you care about
the graphical method?
And a student asked me a
question after lecture last
Thursday, and it occurred to me
that it's not obvious why you
need the graphical method.
So it turns out that often
times you do not have an
equation describing the device.
So let's say,
for example,
I am a manufacturer.
Let's say I am AMD.
As AMD I sit down and my
semiconductor division builds a
MOSFET.
And when you build a MOSFET
your experiments and your
fabrication division often times
doesn't give you an equation
with the MOSFET.
They build something and then
you look at it and you
experiment with it.
You apply various input
voltages and you measure
currents and output voltages and
so on.
And so what you end up getting
is a graph that describes the
behavior of the MOSFET.
And you have seen this in your
lab as well, your 2N7000 or was
it 2000?
So your 2N7000,
the MOSFET you use in the lab
also gives you a data sheet.
And in that data sheet you see
a bunch of curves.
So very often devices come with
data sheets.
And when you have a data sheet
but no equation then you can
apply the graphical method and
solve your circuits.
In this example,
assuming I can apply the
analytical method,
here was the expression that I
had derived for you in the last
lecture.
So VO was related to VI using
the square law relationship.
And we can plot and do other
fun stuff with this equation.
So here is the input voltage
VI.
That is my VT.
So notice that VO is VS.
This is true when VI greater
than or equal to VT and VO
greater than or equal to VI
minus VT.
So these are the constraints of
the saturation discipline.
And in our particular situation
when VI was less than VT output
would simply be VS.
If VI is less than VT the
MOSFET would turn off,
switch off, and I would have no
current flowing through RL,
and VS would appear at the
output.
So until VT,
I have VS, and then following
that I get the square law
behavior articulated by this
equation.
And this was simply VS-K/2
(VI-VT)(RL^2).
So that's the first part.
You have seen this before.
The transfer function shows
that I have a square law
dependence between VI and VO.
So now I can embark on the
second step of my large signal
analysis, and my goal is to find
the valid input operating range.
So what does that mean?
What I am looking to do here
is, for this little circuit,
is drain, source,
gate, VI, VO,
RL and VS.
What I am looking to do is that
given the value of the supply
VS, RL and a MOSFET,
in our case given a MOSFET
implies that it is a given value
of K and a given value of VT for
that MOSFET.
So what I am going to do is
find out, let's assume VI is my
free variable here.
So my goal will be to find out
the range of VI for which this
device stays in saturation.
And I will use a couple of
methods to do that,
and I will use both a
combination of a graphical
method to give you intuition and
then apply analytical analysis
to get down to specific answers.
So let's start with the
intuitive part.
So here is VI,
VO.
I will use the transfer curve
VO versus VI to help build
intuition here.
So that is what it looks like.
So the first step,
looking at this graph,
we know that this point here,
that VI needs to be greater
than VT to satisfy the first
equation.
Let me just write down both
equations here.
So VI greater than or equal to
VT is one of them,
and VO is greater than VI minus
VT is a second equation.
And just remember that this is
the same as VDS and this is the
same as VGS.
So VI must be greater than VT
for the MOSFET to turn on.
And so therefore the valid
operating range starts at this
point and is somewhere up here.
So the first part is pretty
easy.
Somewhere here --
Somewhere at that point,
my output voltage VO.
I'm not quite sure what that
point is.
My output voltage VO,
as this keeps falling down,
my output voltage VO goes lower
than one threshold below VI.
And at that point it goes into
its triode region,
and I need to find out what
that point is.
So somewhere here I go into my
triode region and begin to show
a different behavior than the
amplifying square law
relationship there and go into
my triode behavior.
So I need to find out what this
point is.
Once I find out what that point
is then this will be my valid
operating range.
So let's figure out what that
point is.
At that point the following is
true.
Certainly VI is greater than
VT.
And at that point the output
goes below one threshold,
the input minus one threshold.
So at this point the following
is true, VO is equal to VI minus
VT.
At that point the output
voltage is equal to the input
minus VT.
And if the output goes lower
then it will violate this
equation here.
It is no longer greater than
that number.
So how do we find out what this
point is?
The principle intuition.
Let's draw some lines here.
Let's assume that VI and VT use
the same scale,
say, volts.
So if I draw a straight line at
45 degrees then that is a curve
representing VI equals VO.
We all know that.
No big shakes.
So the line at 45 degrees here
is the line at which VI equal
VO.
And if I take that line now,
the VI equals VO line,
and I begin translating it to
the right.
So let's take a line here.
Let's take a line there.
That line will be simply equal
to VO equals VI minus VT.
I have translated that to the
right.
And so this line is simply VO
equals VI minus VT.
So this line is a locus of
points at which VO is equal to
this value.
This minus VT shows up as a
translation to the right.
So I take my VO equals VI line,
translate that to the right and
it becomes VO equals VI minus
VT.
Elementary geometry 101 or
whatever.
So what do we have here?
Above this we have the
condition VO greater than or
equal to VI minus VT,
and below that we have VO less
than VI minus VT.
If we look at this graph here,
this is the valid input
operating range.
Starting at this point greater
than VT, and at this point my
output equals VO equals VI minus
VT.
This must be the valid
operating range for the input
here to here.
And correspondingly the outputs
are from here to this point to
here like so.
So this is my valid input
operating range and this is my
valid output operating range or
the corresponding valid output
operating range.
So what does this say?
What this is saying is that if
I, as the designer of the
circuit, am disciplined enough
to apply inputs that are in this
range, VT to some value here,
graphically shown here.
Then my MOSFET will remain in
saturation.
And correspondingly my outputs
will go between VS and some
value here.
So hopefully that gives you
some of the intuition behind how
we get it.
And let's continue.
Let me label this point X.
So continuing with two to get
the valid operating range.
I have shown you intuitively
where that point is,
but what I will do next is
actually compute that for you.
It is a pretty simple
computation.
Note that point X is the
intersection of two curves VO
equals VI minus VT.
And the second curve is VO
equals VS minus K divide by 2,
VI minus V2 all squared RL.
So the point X iss at the
intersection of these curves,
and I can very easily get that
as follows.
What I will do is I will simply
substitute for VI minus VT from
this equation here and then
solve for it,
so I get VO equals VS minus K
divide by 2 VO squared RL.
And so this gives me a
quadratic in VO.
And I can solve for it pretty
easily.
And I get for a quadratic AX
squared plus BX plus C equals 0.
The solution is given by VO is
minus B plus/minus square root
of B squared minus 4AC divided
by 2A.
And so I am just going to get
those numbers here.
So the coefficient of VO,
that is B, is minus 1.
Take the positive root because
we are up in the positive
voltages here.
And square root of B squared,
that is 1, minus 4AC.
So I get a plus 4 times K
divide by 2 RL.
And 2A is simply 2 times K
divided by 2 times RL.
So that is what I get.
That gives me VO.
So it tells me that VO,
at the point where the output
just equals one threshold drop
below VI is given by the other
circuit perimeter such as VS,
RL and so on.
Oh, I am missing a VS here.
I just forgot the VS up here.
That is my VO.
So what is VI equal to?
Remember that at this point VO
equals VI minus VT,
so VI is simply VT plus --
I have not taught you anything
earth shattering here.
I have just done some grubby
math here to solve these two
equations.
So this is a straight line at
45 degrees from VT and this is
the transfer function.
And I need to find the
intersection.
And the intersection is given
by this point.
So that point,
VI being VT plus something,
is simply the second dot on the
X axis.
So therefore I am pretty much
done.
My valid input range for VI
goes from VT.
So it starts at VT.
That is where the transistor
just turns on.
And then goes all the way to
this point, VT plus minus 1 plus
square root of 1 plus 2 K RL VS
K RL.
So this is my valid operating
range.
And again remember I won't
dwell on this equation because,
in some sense,
you will get a different set of
limits for other devices,
for other circuits containing a
MOSFET.
Or, for that matter,
for other outputs that one may
be focusing on.
So what is more important here
is not so much the results that
you see but the process that I
have gone through.
So what is more important here
is how did I get here?
And the way I got here was
looked at the graph and said
look, the MOSFET is in
saturation in that regime.
And I am finding the bounding
points of the regime of
saturation operation.
So now, as an engineer,
I can say that hey,
look, if you build a MOSFET
circuit like so,
with a given value of RL,
a given MOSFET and a given VS,
then if you limit yourself you
are operating with input
voltages in this range thou
shalt be happy.
If you go beyond that range
then you will be violating the
saturation discipline.
So the corresponding output
range --
I can write the corresponding
output range,
and that goes from VS,
when the input is at VT the
output is at VS and goes from VS
down to the input minus VT.
Which is simply minus 1 plus --
Let me go back and quickly show
you a little MOSFET circuit,
amplified circuit so you can
stare at a real transfer curve
yourselves.
And indeed convince yourselves
that roughly at the point where
proportionately shown in the
curve up there the MOSFET indeed
goes into its triode region and
begins heading out of its
saturation region.
Notice that here that is the
same curve, the transfer
function.
And the amplified output is at
VS until input reaches a
threshold voltage VT.
And once input goes beyond VT
the output begins to drop
precipitously.
And at some point here this
begins to go into its triode
region.
And what I am going to do is
simply increase the input
voltage VI, and you will see
that the output them begins to
go into its triode region.
It keeps dropping.
And, as you can see,
the output begins to go into a
space where the gain is no
longer more than 1.
And this is a triode region of
MOSFET operation.
So the MOSFET is in saturation,
things are going great.
As I increase my VI notice at
some point I begin to go out of
my saturation region of the
MOSFET.
And somewhere here I go from
the saturation region and
transition into the triode
region.
And this value shown here gives
you the corresponding input
voltage and the output voltage.
Other practical devices like
bipolar junction transistors or
MOSFETs and other circuits and
so on can be subjected to a
similar analysis.
And you can find out the valid
operating regions for that
device as well,
or for that circuit.
So as a next step what I would
like to do --
Out here I began by looking at
the transfer function,
the VO versus VI curve,
and used that to drive the
intuition behind how we
calculated the bounding regions.
You can do the same kind of
analysis intuitively looking at
yet another curve,
another set of graphs that you
are familiar with,
and that is a load line
characteristic.
And it is interesting to get
two interpretations.
And you can use whichever one
you feel comfortable with.
So I will do two alternatively
and show you another set of
curves that you can use to get
that.
Here I am going to plot IDS
versus VDS, which is the same as
VO.
This was the load line graph
that we had seen earlier.
And, just for our reference,
remember that VI must be
greater than VT for saturation
operation.
Similarly VO should be greater
than or equal to VI minus VT for
saturation operation.
Those are my limits.
The way we got the load line
graph was we superimposed the
load line equation over the
device characteristics.
And so let me plot the device
characteristics in the
saturation region.
Remember that this constraint
could be related to the current
as I derived for you in the last
lecture as follows.
IDS being less than or equal to
K divided by 2 VO squared.
So in terms of my IDS versus
VDS relation,
this lateral constraint is
equivalent to IDS being less
than K by 2 VO squared.
So this is that equation.
So this line is IDS equals K by
2 VO squared.
And in this region I have the
valid operating region where IDS
is less than that quality.
So here are all my other curves
for various values VGS.
So here are my devices curves,
IDS versus VDS.
Remember that these curves come
down like this,
for the MOSFET,
right?
Just that we focus on the
right-hand side because that is
where the MOSFET is in
saturation.
And on this side the MOSFET is
in its triode region,
and we discipline ourselves not
to operate the MOSFET such that
it is in its triode region.
So those were the device
characteristics.
And then I could plot my load
line equation.
My load line equation,
if you recall,
was IDS = VS/RL - VO/RL.
This was simply obtained by
writing KVL at the loop
containing the output node and
the supply VS.
Notice there that VO is equal
to VS minus IDS times RL.
And that is simply by dividing
by RL on both sides and moving
IDS to the left-hand side we get
this equation.
And this equation gives rise to
a curve that looks like this.
And what is this point here?
This point is where VO is 0.
So when VO is 0 my IDS is
simply VS divided by RL.
And this point is obtained when
IDS is 0.
And under those conditions VS
and VO are equal so this is VS.
This is my saturation region
and this is the triode region.
This was another interesting
graph.
We often times fondly call it
the load line graph.
So here is a load line
superimposed on the MOSFET
device IDS versus VDS curves for
a variety of values of VGS.
So by looking at this curve,
we can also intuitively
determine the valid operating
range.
So what are the two points
here?
I will let you stare at it for
a couple of seconds yourselves
to figure out what two points
here bound the valid operating
range of the MOSFET,
the valid operating range of
the circuit.
I will start.
One is this point,
because at this point the
output is VS and VGS has just
begun to equal VT.
So think about where the second
point is for valid operation.
It is here, and,
somewhere along that load line.
Remember the load line is a
constraint that must be met by
the output VO.
It is the constraint imposed by
KVL on the output.
So the output is constrained to
operate in this regime for
various values of VGS.
So as the output keeps going
from here all the way here,
at some point I exit my
saturation region.
And that other point is given
by this one.
So notice that this is the
curve that bounds.
On the left-hand side of this
the MOSFET is no longer in
saturation.
It is on the right-hand side,
and so therefore this is the
valid operating region.
Here to here.
This is good.
This is VS.
That is good to know.
And for this point I know that
VI, which is VGS,
equals VT.
I know VO is equal to VS.
And IDS, at this point,
is 0.
So VO and IDS being VS and 0
correspondingly are the output
operating perimeters when VI
equals VD.
So that is one point.
And let's find out what this
point is.
At that point I get my output
just entering the range of the
MOSFET triode region operation.
Notice that this point is the
intersection of two curves,
this line and this curve.
So this curve here is given by
IDS equals K divided by 2 VO
squared.
And this is my load line
equation.
So that is VS divided by RL
minus VO divided by RL.
That's it.
So I won't go ahead and solve
that for you.
You can go and check it out and
convince yourselves that if you
solve these two equations and
find out the VO for this,
it should be the same VO that
you obtained using the other
graph.
What I have done here,
obtaining the valid regions of
operation is no different from
what I did here.
The two are alternative
approaches to getting to the
same place.
Just that over the years what I
have discovered is that there
are one class of people that are
output transfer function people,
this graph, and another set of
people that are load line people
that like to think that way.
I have always been a transfer
function person myself,
but some of you may be load
line people and so you can use
that to drive your intuition.
It is pretty amazing.
As we get into this business
and keep going down the path,
it is amazing how some people
really kind of get the load line
thing and others feel much more
comfortable with the transfer
function.
So pick whatever you want.
So what we have so far is we
have conducted a large signal
analysis of a MOSFET amplifier.
It is an analysis of a circuit,
and we found two things.
One is the transfer function
under saturation operation,
and we found the valid input
operating ranges and the
corresponding valid output
operating ranges for the
circuit.
In the last five or six minutes
let me talk about a couple of
other issues.
And the first issue is what we
have done so far is intuitively
and mathematically shown you
what the valid regions are.
Now you are thinking that's
fine, but how do I get there?
This region is good,
VT through that other point,
that's good,
but how do I get there?
How do I make my amplifier
operate in that region?
The answer is pretty simple,
and let me drive the intuition
again using a graph.
So this is a graph.
And I showed you that --
That was my valid region here.
Take a 45 degree line,
find out where it intersects
the transfer function,
then this is the valid region
here, VT through that
coordinating function that we
developed out there.
If I have an input that looks
like so, some input whose
gyrations fall within this
range, will constantly keep the
MOSFET in saturation.
And the corresponding output
will look like this.
If my input is in this range,
my output will be within this
range.
And how do I get my input to be
here?
Let's say I have a sinusoid
that is 1 volt peak to peak or
whatever.
How do I get my sinusoid up
there?
Well, you have learned the
trick on how to boost things.
Remember boost?
All you have to do is boost up
your signal by some value
capital VI.
And the way you do that is as
follows.
VS, RL, VO.
What you do is you apply a DC
offset to your input.
You take your sinusoid and
boost it up so that all the
gyrations of the input are in
the valid range.
This is my input,
some VA.
Then I apply some DC offset
capital VI given by this value
here.
And boost up the interesting
input?
My interesting input is the VA.
And I boost it up by capital VI
so that this guy is always in
saturation.
I would like to show you a
little demo now.
I am going to show you an input
that is a triangular wave.
And what we will do is I'll
play with a wide variety of
offset voltages.
This guy is a triangular wave.
And what I am going to do is
apply a triangular wave and
we'll look at the output and
convince ourselves that I get
amplification when VI is big
enough that the input goes into
a valid operating range.
And we will look at a variety
of ranges here.
You can put it a little larger.
OK.
So the triangular wave is my
input.
And this is my output.
This looks nothing like a
triangular wave.
And the reason is that I do not
have the right offset.
So what I will do is gradually
increase the offset on the
MOSFET.
So at this point the offset is
very low, a very small near zero
offset.
And so therefore my output is a
disaster.
My MOSFET is not in saturation
all the time.
So what I will do here is apply
some sort of offset.
Is this the one?
We want to switch.
This is the input.
You can see I am applying an
offset by bumping and boosting
up the input.
I don't have clipping happening
at both ends,
but I get something.
And I get amplification.
Now let me apply way too much
of an offset.
With this offset I am kind of
operating here.
What I will do now is apply an
even higher offset so that this
triangular wave begins to move
here.
If I apply a very high offset
what I am doing is overdriving
the amplifier,
boosting it so high that the
MOSFET is going to go into its
triode region and you are going
to see that I won't have any
gain.
My output is going to shrink
noticeably if I overdrive the
input.
You will notice the input going
higher and higher.
Pull the trigger point down.
There you go.
Notice that as I boost up my
input even higher notice that
the output is a really small
image of what the right input
should be.
The right answer here,
of course, is that I apply some
right amount of offset to boost
up the input into the right
regime so that the output is
seen to be some amplified
version of this input.
So I showed you three things.
One is very little offset.
That was like so,
as the thing comes down.
A very high offset,
it gets killed again.
And the right amount of offset.
But notice that we still have a
problem, even with the right
offset.
The output is not linearly
related to the input.
It is nonlinear.
And the answer to get a linear
response is good old small
signal stuff.
And we will be looking at the
small signal part in the next
lecture.